So in the last lecture I spent
quite a while trying to convey a
sense of
how the structure of DNA was
discovered.
The crystallographic
data that led to it,
as I said, was collected by
Rosalind Franklin.
And
I saw there was some confusion
about this picture that I showed
you next.
This is not a photograph of a
double helix.
This is what happened when she
bounced the x-ray off the
crystal of
DNA.
This is the diffraction pattern
that she saw.
And then one
works backwards from that
trying to figure out what kind
of structure it
was that would have caused that
diffraction pattern.
And you have
to be a pretty good x-ray
crystallographer to draw any
kind of
inferences from that.
And there were people,
including Francis
Crick, who saw the implications
of it right away.
But the point was she collected
the data and then two people
that I told
you about then whose name you
know so well,
Jim Watson and Francis
Crick, were the two individuals
that came up with the model that
explained the diffraction
pattern.
And therefore we learned the
structure of DNA as a
double-stranded helix.
I also tried
to make the case that it wasn't
two geniuses who sat down in the
room,
took a look at this and popped
up with the model.
It was a story of real people
with misadventures and mistakes
and
recovery from mistakes and so
on getting it.
It was also a very
small group.
And I'm going to take just a
very small minute at the
beginning of the class because
I have a colleague,
Vernon Ingram
who's sitting down here in the
front, who was a member of this
very
small group with Jim Watson and
Francis Crick.
So he was there
where all this happened.
And almost nobody in the world
has
had a chance in your generation
to hear directly from somebody
who was
there when it happened.
So asked Vernon if he would
come and just
talk to you for a little bit
just what it was like to be
there.
Well, thanks,
Graham.
You seem to
be at a very exciting state in
7.014.
This structure of the secret of
life no less.
And it is interesting
that immediately when Watson
and Crick put together a model
of the
DNA molecule that fit the x-ray
data, that was the point,
how do you
know a model is correct?
Because there are certain
distances
in the model,
and those have to correlate
exactly with the distances
of the x-ray spots in the
diffraction pattern that you
saw.
That is how you know that a
model that you've built to
certain
specifications corresponds to
what the molecule of itself in
the
crystal that you're examining
actually is composed of.
It was by sheer accident that I
happened to be working as a
biochemist in the MRC,
The Medical Research Council
lab at the
Cavendish Laboratory where
Watson and Crick were working.
Sheer
accident.
It was a very crowded lab,
as Graham said.
And that's something that you
should remember.
When you're choosing a
lab to work in,
always go to a lab that's
overcrowded.
Never go to a
lab where there's lots of space
because a really successful lab
attracts so many coworkers,
visitors that it rapidly gets
overcrowded.
And that was the case in this
laboratory.
The director was Max
Perutz.
Co-director John Kendrew doing
x-ray crystallography of
proteins for almost the first
time, and solving the protein
structure.
Francis Crick was a graduate
student of Max Perutz's doing
his PhD work.
And the first thing I remember
about Francis was when I went
there as a
biochemist to work with Max
Perutz, when I went there,
there was this
tall gangling guy constantly
circulating between the top
floor of
the building,
his office in the middle and
the x-ray machines at the
bottom.
He was constantly going up and
down.
And in those days the
buildings didn't have an
elevators or lifts as the
English
called them.
So he was in excellent physical
shape.
Very crowded,
a very modest lab.
And what's usually forgotten
is a key member of that group,
an engineer,
Tony Broad, key person
because he invented what was
then the world's best and most
efficient
x-ray machine,
a rotating anode x-ray machine.
And because to the x-ray
crystallographers in that group
this
machine was available,
because of that they were the
preeminent x-ray
structure group in the world.
My job was as a biochemist,
protein
biochemist, putting a heavy
atom, mercury,
very heavy atom into Max
Parutz's hemoglobin crystals in
specific places.
That has a predictable effect
on the x-ray pattern and that
enables the
Fourier diagram to be
constructed with real phase
values for the x-ray
diffractions,
for the physicists among you
here.
Are there any physicists here?
Yeah, I thought so.
That was a big
step forward and that was also
a big step in figuring out the
structure
of the DNA samples
semi-crystals that Professor
Walker
just referred to.
All dependent on the engineer
Tony
Broad who is never mentioned in
any of these histories,
but without him
this would not have happened.
So it was an exciting place to
work in,
very exciting.
We were all young in those
days.
And living the lives of
young men and young women with
all the complications that arise
when
you put a whole bunch of very
energetic young men,
very energetic
young women together.
And by that I mean the
interpersonal
relationships which when you're
in a crowded,
very active situation can
sometimes interfere.
And always very entertaining,
I can tell you
that.
I could give you chapter and
verse.
But it isn't really so very
different from people your age
now, right?
I mean I'm not saying it
interferes with you,
sometimes it might.
But
it was an exciting lab,
an exciting time to be there
because we were not
the only group trying to figure
out the structure of DNA.
A huge
competitor was Linus Pauling at
Caltech who had beaten that same
group once before,
quite recently,
over the alpha helix,
the crucial
component of protein structure.
He got the right answer first,
1.5
angstrom reflection,
the alpha helix.
And our group,
Max Parutz
and our group had been wrong.
So the group was smarting under
that
kind of defeat,
if you like.
And competition is a wonderful
spur,
as long as you don't let it get
out of hand.
Well, needless to say we
didn't, but the competition
with the Pauling lab was
certainly so severe
that we awaited the next
letter.
You see, in those days new
scientific information arrived
not by publications,
that too much too
long, but by personal letter.
And, in fact,
the NIH has put together
all these various letters in
the Francis Crick collection.
And when
you have time you should look
at those.
They're quite interesting
because they tell you in a way
a scientific paper does not tell
you.
What I feel about my experiment
results.
What she feels about her
experiment results.
What it means to me as a
person, to her as a
person, to him as a person.
So we were constantly watching
the mail
and discussing the news as it
came in, mostly over a beer at
the pub
next door.
It was very conveniently
located.
But being a small group crowded
together made communication
within
our group very easy indeed.
And we had fights.
I don't mean physical
fights.
We had scientific fights.
And as a biochemist I was able
to
settle a crucial fight among
the crystallographers Crick and
Watson
who were building the model.
Because, quite frankly,
they didn't
know much chemistry.
And were trying to build a
model with the
wrong confirmation of the
peptide bond.
They didn't realize that the
peptide bond has two possible
confirmations.
And they had at one
point a terrible time trying to
fit everything together because
they
were using the wrong
confirmation.
I'm talking about lactam-lactim
for
those of you who are organic
chemists and it means something,
a
confirmation.
And once they got the first
confirmation then the model
clicked into place.
So we all helped,
that's what I'm trying to
say.
We all helped with one great
aim in mind.
It was clear.
And you
know from what Professor Walker
said, that the DNA structure,
in its
structure held the clue to
crucial physiological behavior
of DNA.
And Crick and Watson said this
in their first paper,
the structure
itself because of its
complimentarity gives you an
immediate clue as to how it
replicates.
And replication of DNA
structure from generation to
generation is,
of course, the
crucial thing about DNA.
The copying,
the precise copying
from generation to generation.
And that fell out the of x-ray
structure.
That's why the x-ray structure
was so very important,
because it gave you an
immediate understanding of the
role of DNA in
modern biology.
So that's what we did.
And eventually the people in
the group, the group got so
overcrowded
they built a huge lab that was
beautiful, like any new lab is.
But
the thing I remember most of
all was the atmosphere in that
place.
So
remember, when you go and
choose a lab,
choose one that's overcrowded.
It will pay off. [APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
That was really wonderful.
Thank you.
I don't know if some of you
realized
quite how rare that was,
this discovery of the structure
of DNA.
As I said, probably one of the
big discoveries of mankind.
Because, as
Vernon said,
you could see so many of the
secrets of life as soon as
you saw that structure.
Very few people have ever heard
from someone
who was there at the time.
Maybe you'll forget a bunch of
stuff down
the line, but I hope you'll
remember you heard somebody who
was there
when Watson and Crick were
there and maybe his extra piece
of advice
about choosing a lab.
To say one thing quickly,
some of
you I think understood what
I've been trying to do.
I spent quite a
bit of time talking about
science being done by real
people doing real
experiments.
Thanks for your comments.
A few of you have gone
out of your way to say that
this was a total waste of time
and you didn't
understand why I didn't teach
you something instead of doing
something
on the test.
Well, I'm making up the test.
And if you don't think
there'll be something on
scientific process on the second
exam
you'll be surprised.
So I'm spending a lot of time
on
this, and the reason is because
you are MIT students.
You know, you can
go many places in the country
to many high school biology
courses and
you can memorize,
someone will tell you to
memorize everything that's in
the book, and you'll get tested
whether you can memorize it.
You
guys are at MIT because you
have the potential to be leaders
in whatever
you do.
I've made the transition from
being an undergrad sort of
trying to memorize stuff in a
textbook to working
on a cutting-edge.
I've made some reasonably
significant discoveries in
science, as have my other
colleagues in the
department, some of them making
greater than I.
But nevertheless if
you're on the cutting-edge then
you're dealing with all the
stuff
I'm trying to tell you about in
this thing.
You're working as a part of
a group.
There's competition.
There are interpersonal
relationships.
You make mistakes.
You recover from them.
You're
making inferences.
You're testing models.
This is a very complex,
very real, very dynamic,
very human interaction.
I hope you got a
little bit of whiff of that
from Vernon.
And I wouldn't be,
I'm quite capable of
reproducing diagrams from the
textbook without trying to give
you a deeper understanding,
and that's
what I'm trying to do here.
And I hope if it hasn't made
sense to you
by the end that at least a few
more of you will get it.
And those of
you who I think saw what I was
doing I appreciate your telling
me that in
the things.
These are anonymous so I don't
know, but a couple of you
are certainly trying to make it
clear that you didn't think it
was
worth your time coming to
lecture.
I'm trying to tell you why I'm
trying to do it.
I'm trying to teach you in a
deeper way.
And this
is a required course.
It's important for your life.
I hope
some of you will see that or if
you don't see it now you'll see
it later
in your career.
OK.
Now, we're going to talk about
DNA replication.
I'm going to start to drive
into some of the details that
maybe are
more the kind of things you're
expecting.
I just want to make one
quick point here.
I've talked about cell division
and
we saw this,
how cells come from other cells
going to make more
cells.
I showed you this little movie
you've seen a few times of a
yeast cell dividing,
but all cells divide.
Here's a cancer cell
dividing.
If you get a cancer it's a cell
that's forgotten how to stop
dividing and is growing to make
a tumor.
There's this cancer cell
dividing.
It looks not unlike a yeast on
a molecular level,
very,
very similar.
But there's another point.
I told you how the structure of
DNA with the complimentary
strands with
G pairing with C and A pairing
with T immediately gave rise to
an
insight as to how the genetic
material could be replicated.
And
you guys know that it's held
together by hydrogen bonds
between
base pairs which are about
one-twentieth the strength of
the
covalent bonds.
So you're able to peel the
strands apart without
breaking the covalent bonds.
And then by pairing A with T
and G with
C and doing that on both
strands then you can end up with
two identical copies.
And so if you do two identical
copies and you do it again you
get eight.
One of the things we've
realized over the last two or
three years in looking through
the exams
is somehow, at least some of
the class, didn't connect the
business
about cells coming from other
cells and DNA duplicating to
give daughter
DNA.
And I'm just trying to hammer
home the point that these are
related.
Every time a cell divides it
has to duplicate its
genetic information.
That's why I'm going to be
telling
you about DNA replication.
Here's a picture of that same
cancer cell,
but watch over here.
This is the DNA.
And you see it's doubled.
And
see how the DNA,
which is the chromosomes,
has pulled apart so
that at the end you now have
two cells and you've got
identical
copies of DNA.
So if you're studying cancer,
for example,
this
sort of thing is relevant to
you.
OK.
So the issue of how --
Well, before I do that,
I'm sorry.
Just a couple of things about
DNA
replication before I dive into
this.
So we all started out as a
single
cell.
I've got a lot more obviously
because I'm made up of a lot of
cells.
If I took all the DNA in my
body and I wind up all the
molecules
in it, do you guys have any
idea how long that would be?
Who thinks it
would reach let's say across
the room?
OK.
Across campus?
Across Cambridge?
Around the world?
To
the moon?
Anybody left?
To the sun?
I've got ten to the fourteenth
cells.
There's about a meter or two in
each cell.
10 to 20 billion
miles of DNA in each of our
bodies, human DNA.
They would go back and forth to
the sun multiple times.
So that much
DNA had to get replicated in
order for the fertilized egg we
all
started out as to become you.
Another thing,
the accuracy of
replication is about ten to the
minus tenth.
Most people,
including
myself, don't have a very good
feel for exponents.
So that's one
mistake in 10 billion.
You know, it could be one
mistake in
10 to the ninety-ninth.
Well, what is one mistake in 10
billion mean?
So let's relate it to something
we know.
If I was typing let's say an
eight letter word,
60 words a minute,
24 hours a day,
7 days a
week, and I was as good as DNA
replication, how often would I
make
a mistake?
So you can each think of how
long you think that is.
But if
I was good on average,
I would make a mistake once
every 38 years.
So I'm about to tell you about
a process that's absolutely
astonishing in terms of how
fast and how much you can do and
with an
accuracy that goes beyond what
we're used to in our ordinary
life.
So
how does it do this?
It has to be more than just
pulling the strands
apart.
And there's been some confusion
as to why I'm emphasizing
5 prime and 3 prime.
Well, each of these subunits,
each
nucleotide, this is a 3 prime
hydroxyl and this is the 5 prime
position.
If we were joining together
subunits that had a hook
and an eye it would make a
difference because it's not the
same
on both ends.
If we're going to start hooking
together it's exactly
the same thing when we get to a
biochemical level,
the 5 prime end
is not the same as hydroxyl at
the 3 prime end because the
whole
thing is asymmetric.
So the enzymes that copy DNA
are
known as DNA polymerases.
And it was a very difficult
challenge to
figure out how they operated,
but Arthur Kornberg was the
first person
to solve this problem.
He was an extraordinarily
gifted
biochemist.
He's still at Stanford.
And what he found was if we
have a
5 prime end this would then be
the 3 prime end,
and there's a 3 prime
hydroxyl which is this one
right here.
And this was paired,
say,
with a C and A paired with a T.
And let's say a G paired with a
C
here.
And let's say the next template
base was, let's make it a
T.
What Arthur Kornberg was able
to find was an enzyme activity
that
catalyzed a template-dependent
replication of DNA.
That was
critical because he had to
find, if you broke the cells
open, somewhere
in that gamish of enzymes and
things from inside a cell.
There had to be something that
was able to copy DNA.
So in order to do
that he had to work out an
assay.
And he also had to have some
kind of
guess as to what the cell would
be using in order to carry out
the
synthesis.
But one thing that was sort of
obvious was a DNA template
because that was being copies.
But the other part was you had
to have
energy to form a covalent bond.
So somehow there had to be
something
that was sort of activated with
the energy built into the
molecule so
that thermodynamically the
whole thing would slide downhill
when you
made a bond.
And he knew that the cell had
triphosphates,
just the
same type that we talked about
when we talked about ATP.
So this would be a
deoxyribonucleotide
triphosphate.
And he was able to make a
guess,
because he had to try things
until he found something that
would work,
that this was what's used in
DNA synthesis.
So this hydroxyl ultimately
attacks this phosphate here.
And these two
other phosphates then come off
as a leaving group.
So if we thought of
it as a P like this with two
more Ps here,
these two come off and
you get a new bond formed to
the phosphate.
And so what Kornberg then was
able to find by using a DNA
template that
had this sort of structure and
P, P, P, like this,
that he was now
able to get an A added here.
This hydroxyl here became
the new hydroxyl.
And so the direction of
synthesis,
this strand is the other way,
so the direction of synthesis
of a DNA
polymerase, it's polymerizing
in the 5 prime to 3 prime
direction.
This was again an amazing
discovery because it was the
first time that
anyone had found an enzyme that
could copy DNA.
Arthur Kornberg got a Nobel
Prize for it.
But at this point actually
genetics came in because there
was a scientist John Cairns who
was at
that point down at Cold Spring
Harbor, as I told you the other
day.
And John, in spite of the fact
that Arthur had found a DNA
polymerase
that had all the properties
that you would expect for
copying DNA, didn't
think that was the one that
actually copied the DNA
necessary for
cellular replication.
So he reasoned if he was right
he'd
be able to find a mutation that
would eliminate the activity of
that
enzyme and the cell would still
live.
And so they did a screen,
and it was a lot of work,
but they eventually found a
mutant of E.
coli
that lacked this DNA polymerase
that Arthur Kornberg had
discovered.
And
the cell was still alive and
was still replicating its DNA.
So it
told both John and then Arthur
there must be another enzyme in
the cell.
And so Arthur went back.
And now working in a mutant
that was missing
this first polymerase he
discovered he found the one that
really
replicates the DNA.
The first one is important,
too.
It's needed for
DNA repair.
I'm going to talk to you about
that in next lecture,
but
it's not absolutely crucial for
life.
And there's an interplay of
genetics and biochemistry.
And you'll see I'm just sort of
foreshadowing what we're going
to get to when we talk about
the genetics of this.
And I know a couple of you
clearly
were frustrated about me
showing you pictures of the
people who did this,
but nevertheless since this was
such a historic event a couple
of years
ago at Cold Spring Harbor.
This you see the helix model
down there.
There was Jim Watson opening
the symposium.
When I got up to talk I
said, well, I told my students
that I'd let them know what it
was like
when I was there,
so I took out a camera and I
took a picture of the
audience.
And so there are a bunch of
Nobel Laureates and types here
who were sitting there smiling
for you guys in the class.
And there
was Arthur Kornberg giving his
talk.
Now, these DNA polymerases are
incredible protein machines.
The
crystal structures of DNA
polymerases operating their
template
have been solved.
And you can solve,
depending on how many
diffractions you can get,
you can get a model that's more
and more
detailed.
And there have been very high
resolution models of DNA
polymerases.
This blue and white stuff is
the surface of the protein,
and this is sort of a template
and the various parts.
Just to give you an idea here
are these tracings of the shapes
of the
electron density.
You can see how the
crystallographers have fit the
nucleotides right in the
crystal into these electron
densities.
And
here putting it together a bit
in the blue is the secondary
structure
of the protein and the
templates and whatnot.
And I don't expect you to
see very much in that,
but the point is I wanted to
sort of just set you
up to show you this little
movie.
Because DNA polymerases are
incredible machines.
They copy at about a thousand
nucleotides a
second and their accuracy is
really amazing.
And I'll tell you all the
tricks to the accuracy in the
next lecture,
but I want to show you this
little movie because this is
sort of a simulation of what
must happen
every time a nucleotide is
added.
Now, we'll see this over and
over
again so I'll take it in
pieces.
The yellow and the orange are
the
secondary structures.
That's an alpha helix.
And certainly one
thing you can see is happening,
as we're looking at this,
is the parts
of the protein are moving
during this.
So you can see this alpha
helix that's sort of swinging
up and swinging back down.
Now, what's
over here is the template base.
That's the base that
correspondents
to the T that I was just
showing you here.
This is the incoming
nucleotide.
There is the triphosphate
coming
down here.
And, in fact,
you just see those two
phosphates going.
So
what's happening here,
this is going to be the end of
the growing chain.
It's going attack right there,
join the phosphate and the
pyrophosphate
will leave.
And if you'll take a look,
when you see this movement of
this helix from the beginning
state to up to here,
you'll
see what happens.
It's squeezing the template
base and
the incoming nucleotide
together.
What it's really doing is
testing
for the correct shape.
Remember the shape of an A-T
base pair and a G-C
base pair is the same.
And if those of you who are
confused about
guanine and the keto-enol
thing, try to draw hydrogen
bonds with the enol
form of guanine and see how you
do.
I think you'll begin to
understand a bit.
So at the heart of life is
something
that can copy DNA.
And there are these exquisitely
beautiful
machines.
The replicative machine in E.
coli has 18 proteins and the
ones in our bodies are even
more sophisticated with even
more parts.
OK.
But to replicate a DNA molecule
there's another problem
that comes up.
Because DNA polymerases copy --
-- and grow chains in a 5 prime
to 3
prime direction.
And they need a 3 prime hydroxy
terminus.
So they won't work if you
just gave it a single strand of
DNA.
No DNA polymerase can handle
that.
It has to have something like
this where there's a template
strand --
-- and there's what's known as
the
primer strand.
So there has to be something
that has the 3 prime
hydroxyl and there has to be
something that's going to
provide
the template that's going to be
copied.
So if we pull strands apart
like this with 5 prime to 3
prime then they'll be 5 prime to
3 prime
running in the opposite
direction.
If we have a template like
this,
this is OK because the strand
here can be copied 5 prime to 3
prime.
This is the new strand being
synthesized by the DNA
polymerase.
But what about the other
strand?
The replication fork is moving
in
this direction,
but if the -- So here is the 3
to 5 prime
direction here.
So if the DNA polymerase is
going to be copying
this strand it's going to be
moving backwards to the
direction of the
replication fork.
Now, I guess evolution and
nature could have
selected for two types of DNA
polymerases, one that copies 5
prime
to 3 prime and one that copies
in the opposite direction.
But it didn't.
And there are a number of
theoretical reasons that we
could discuss in a more advanced
course
perhaps for why that is true.
But, in fact,
what it does is it uses the
same polymerase.
So as these things peel apart
the polymerase works in
the other direction,
but there's another problem.
If I just peel it
apart like this there's no 3
prime hydroxyl.
So it took people quite a
few years to figure out the
strategy that's used in nature.
Nature has a special enzyme
that makes a little piece of
RNA.
It's
called an RNA primer.
And what it does is it provides
a 3 prime
hydroxyl.
And once you have the 3 prime
hydroxyl at the end of the
little RNA chain then the DNA
polymerase --
-- can be made 5 prime to 3
prime.
So as you peel open the
replication fork then little
pieces of RNA are
used to make a new strand of
DNA and it goes this way.
Now that
obviously doesn't give you a
new intact DNA strand.
And part of the clue to this
working out what was going on at
DNA
replication was the recognition
that newly synthesized DNA was
made as
little pieces.
And then later it got joined
into longer pieces.
And
the person who discovered this
was Okazaki.
So these fragments of DNA
that are synthesized initially
are called Okazaki fragments,
after the
person who discovered this.
It was rather puzzling because
when
you tried to look at the
synthesis of DNA you're looking
at a long
molecule, and you found some of
the newly synthesized material
was in
short pieces.
And as you watched over time it
got longer.
So the
cell, I think you can sort of
see from first principles what
has to
happen here then.
That in order to come and make
--
This strand is pretty easy to
do,
but what the cells have to do
now is they've got these little
RNA primers.
And then they remove the RNA by
an enzyme that's capable of
degrading
the DNA or clipping it at the
junction.
And that then leaves the cell
in this sort of situation where
there
are little tiny gaps in between
these pieces of DNA.
But at the end
of each one of these is a 3
prime hydroxyl.
So another polymerase or
one or another polymerase in
the cell can fill those little
pieces of DNA out.
And then there's one little
nick
that needs to be sealed.
And so what you finally end up
with is a 3
prime hydroxyl here,
a 5 prime phosphate that's at
the other end,
and then these are joined
together.
This is one nucleotide here and
the
other here.
These are then joined together
to give the ordinary
phosphodiester bond that links
--
-- the two nucleotides together
like that.
And the enzyme that does that
is an enzyme called DNA ligase.
You can almost think about it
as DNA
Scotch tape that will take a
little nick in DNA,
if we've got a
phosphate and hydroxyl,
and it will join them together.
So this process of replication,
which can go at about a
thousand
nucleotides a second with this
amazing degree of accuracy,
uses two
different DNA polymerases,
both of which biochemically can
only go in
one direction.
But you can see they have to be
somehow oriented so that
one of them is able to move in
this direction and the other one
is able
to move in that direction.
The key part in this sort of
the
course is to try and understand
this 5 to 3 prime and to get
this basic
idea that nature had to do
something.
It was fairly easy to
copy one strand because that
was sort of the direction of the
polymerase movement was the
same as the replication fork
movement, but
the other strand had to have
been much more a problem.
And so when you get down to a
biochemical level,
though, it's very
conceptually easy to say,
oh, you've got complimentary
strands so we just
take it apart,
we take the photograph and the
negative and we
make the opposite one and now
we've got two copies.
When you get down
to the biochemical details
there is this major biochemical
issue of
whether the polymerase can go
in the 3 prime or the 5 prime
direction.
And nature has chosen to do it
all or has been selected to do
it all
somehow with a polymerase going
in one direction.
There are many other aspects to
DNA replication.
And one of the tricks
that I find most fascinating is
that these polymerases,
once they get on
DNA they stay on.
And that's part of the secret
because it takes about
a millisecond to add a
nucleotide, but if it comes off
the DNA it has
to get back on.
Then it takes about a minute.
So the whole trick to being a
very, very fast DNA polymerase
is to
somehow hang onto the DNA.
So what biochemists did was
they purified
the actual enzymatic activity
that could carry out this
process, and
then they started to look for
other protein factors that would
help the
process to work better.
And they discovered something
called a
processivity factor which made
the polymerase stay on the DNA.
And
people wondered for a lot of
years how that worked and why
did this
system work so well.
And finally the crystal
structure of
the processivity factor was
discovered.
And if I go back to
this sort of diagram where this
is the piece of DNA that's
copied, what
it turned out was that the
processivity factor is basically
a
doughnut that kind of gets
clamped around the DNA like
that.
So it's
sort of like taking a washer
with a place where you can pry
it apart
opening it up,
putting it around the DNA like
this.
And then the polymerase,
more or less since this is
topologically
linked to the DNA,
is like a washer sliding on a
wire.
This DNA
polymerase hangs onto that and
it doesn't come off.
And I think
there's a little picture of it.
Here's a little movie.
There's the
DNA going through and this is
one of these clamps.
It's virtually the
same structure in a bacterium
and inside of us.
But, in fact,
the amino acids are almost all
different.
But the
underlying structure of the
protein is almost identical.
And there are
special machines called clamp
loaders that pry open this
clamps,
clamp them around DNA,
and that's part of the secret
to how these
polymerases are able to
polymerize DNA so fast.
There are a lot of
other pieces of this machinery.
If you go on you'll hear more
about
them.
I just want to give you one of
the most recent insights.
I mean
this, as you might guess,
since DNA replication is at the
heart of life
it's been studied very,
very hard, ever since the
discovery of DNA
helix.
My colleague,
Alan Grossman,
made quite a discovery just
probably
three or four years ago.
He took that green fluorescent
protein that
we've seen a few times,
and he actually joined the gene
encoding
green fluorescent protein to
the backend of a piece of
the DNA polymerase.
So wherever the DNA polymerase
went
now there was a little
fluorescent molecule.
And he looked to see
where it was in the cell.
And I, like many other people,
had for
years taught,
and this is why,
you know, I have respect for
the fact
that I'm just teaching you the
current model.
For much of my
career I taught,
so DNA polymerase is sort of
like a train going down
the tracks a thousand molecules
per second.
And we're doing all this stuff
with the leading and with the
two
strands.
So let me just put those words
up while I'm up there.
This
one is called,
this strand that's easy to
replicate is called the
leading strand.
And this one where you have to
do the primer and
whatnot is called the lagging
strand.
In any case,
what I had taught was that
polymerase was like a train
running on tracks.
You could calculate how fast it
would move.
What Alan, to his amazement,
found was when he looked to see
where the DNA polymerase was,
it wasn't spread out all over
the cell
as if you thought it was a
thing running on tracks.
In fact, it was
in the center of the cell.
And then late in cell division
it split into
two spots that went to the
midpoints of what would be the
daughter cells.
And so what he ended up
realizing
from that was that instead it
was more as if the polymerase
was a
factory and it pulled the DNA
through it rather than it
traveling
down the tracks of the DNA.
And that was a very surprising
discovery
that went against all the dogma
and all the pictures in the
textbook.
And it was a discovery at MIT.
That was published in,
I think it
was 2001, something like that,
a very recent discovery.
Things keep
changing.
That's again why I keep
emphasizing I cannot teach you a
fact in biology.
I can teach you the best
understanding we have that
explains the experiments to
date.
But somebody may make a
discovery
tomorrow.
That means we'll have to change
our understanding.
OK?
So good luck on the exam.
Ill see you on Monday,
OK?